Casa de trouver elle s'était endormie pendant l'
anniversaire de la sauce Dupree tante il a commandé un
désir bien que montre le total
exceptionnel
[Musique]
Chaussures Kanaka
alors Liam voulait que je
[Musique]
la vidéo soit terminée
Initiative Intel de l'Université qui
concerne  vous payez normalement un super
hola
avec Odeon peut combattre
[Musique]
moins déplacer notre passage
à l'
imbécile
Sylla surface sous Devaney Asuka Jude
façon
[Musique]
Newsom netizen Jerry Morales Odie donne
yo holla pony horse
San Sebastopol
come two o'clock
II don'  t
la kibriya
cette fois
supposons que la vodka soigne les comédies femmes
[Musique]
sympa moi
bien placer la
[Musique]
- qu'est-ce que tu lui as laissé encore
pas d'obscurité
[Musique]
Nikki liebe
assis plus  les gens
[Musique]
donc pas de connectivité
latoya la nouvelle politique de dauphin eeeh
[Applaudissements]
toi
[Musique]
mais le passé est mort le seul moyen de devenir
un censé être l'
obscurité se lève la nuit pour se rencontrer
[Musique]
J'ai besoin de quelqu'un pour  Montre-moi ma place dans
tout ça
[M  usic]
ça ne va pas disparaître tu penses
que
tout le monde arrête l'
action épisode 8 ça alors le premier film
n'avait même pas de numéro
Ryan a écrit une histoire qui est
inattendue mais juste
certaines des choses qui se passent les gens
ne seront pas oh mon dieu
même si je pense que je sais tout, ils
lancent des choses avec une histoire que je n'aurais jamais
pu imaginer et même si
tout le monde sait que c'est le deuxième d'une
trilogie, on a l'impression que c'est propre
Star Wars est tellement cool parce qu'il y a toutes
ces créatures
toutes ces incroyables  les effets visuels
comme tous les personnages sont aussi si
complexes
Brian sympa les travailleurs Wilkie vend
un nouveau réalisateur particulier Connie vicious
lana wiki sound
on dirait que les scénarios deviennent
plus établis,
nous apprenons vraiment à connaître ces nouveaux
personnages aussi avec les personnages que
nous connaissons et  love
man lives change
tout est en train de changer dans le
sens opposé à ce que le public
attendait après 7h00
Brian a rendu Star Wars frais et nouveau
j'espère que ça va  être un peu choquant,
mais j'espère que cela semblera réel et
honnête.
L'histoire de la fermentation du bien contre le
mal se
déroule de la manière la plus fascinante, mais elle
a un véritable esprit ou une profondeur, il
s'agit de la famille et c'est ce qui est si
puissant
[  Musique] en
remontant la rampe, en marchant dans le
couloir, je me souviens quand j'étais enfant
et avec les figurines d'action à l'intérieur
, j'ai soudainement eu comme une grosse boule dans la
gorge
ouais je suppose que ouais Ryan fait beaucoup de
choses inattendues et emmène les personnages
dans de nouvelles directions  les histoires individuelles de
ces personnages sont élevées et rendues
fraîches et nouvelles
[Musique]
c'est ce que j'aime dans l'approche de Ryan
à l'histoire c'est comme un véritable voyage de
découverte
et messieurs bienvenue à l'épisode 8
premier tournage avec marque premier
tournage avec Daisy
première fois  tourner un film Star Wars
et nous avons eu des trucs sympas
tristes comme un gémissement de chien La merveilleuse
personnalité de Ryan est partout dans ce film, il a des
défauts dans d'autres domaines, je ne sais tout simplement pas
qu'il y a le  chose étrange qui se produit
quand il est en cours de construction lorsque lorsque vous vous
présentez pour la première fois, vous en avez un peu fini
avec les cordes du tout, puis vous entrez
dans le vif du sujet de travailler dessus
naturellement, ce niveau disparaît et
vous trouvez  concentrez-vous simplement sur le fait que
la scène fonctionne, prenez les photos,
puis de temps en temps, vous faites une
petite pause et vous vous asseyez et vous
regardez autour
de vous pour obtenir la couronne sacrée.
un gars très sympa
[Musique]
quand je t'ai trouvé, j'ai vu Bella brute et indomptée
et au-delà de ça quelque chose de vraiment spécial
[Musique]
quelque chose à côté de moi a toujours été mais
j'étais éveillé J'ai besoin d'aide
J'ai vu cette tribune une seule fois auparavant
mais ça m'a trop fait peur  assez
qu'il le fasse maintenant
[Musique]
mais le passe-temps le
tue
si vous avez
le seul moyen de devenir une douleur monumentale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes la petite étincelle qui allume le feu
[Musique]
ça ne va pas
où tu penses
[Musique]
oui chérie
je  besoin de quelqu'un pour me montrer ma place dans
tout ça
[Musique]
toi
[Applaudissements
] [Musique]
Bree
[Musique]
juste
tendre la main comme
[Musique] l'
obscurité
l'équilibre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[  Musique]
Je ne connais qu'une seule vérité,
il est temps que les Jedi s'arrêtent